when we met you
mentioned that there was an Indian Prime
Minister who said we're going to make
non-dualism the pizza of India oh yeah
so can you talk about that and also talk
about some of the misconceptions that
many people in the west have about
non-dualism okay I I I remember I
remember this conversation because I was
recently just having um Pizza dinner
with my
uncle I was having dinner with my uncle
in uh London and he was asking me to
teach him some stuff about Indian phosy
and I actually explained to him this
very same thing because it's a very good
thing to understand so for lack of a
better
analogy uh I'll say it the same way I
said it to you basically and I hope your
audience finds it humorous but I think
it would be really bad if we walked
around thinking the greatest
contribution of Italian cuisine to the
world was pizza and pasta because
there's so many wonderful things in
Italian food that just don't have to do
with Pizza and Pasta for example I was
watching a show yesterday about umbre
and lentils and how interesting it is
and what you can do with uman lentils
and making Italian salads and I found it
totally fascinating and super
interesting to think about making for
myself so it's the same thing um R
Krishan uh the first sort of major
figure of philosophy to step into the
global space he was the Spalding chair
of Eastern religions at Oxford in the
early part of the Century um at one
point kind of made a decision that um he
kind of needed to like explain sort of
what's the big contribution that Indian
philosophers are making to the world and
he tended to have an advian idea about
it he was kind of like well this is the
one thing we've got this non-dualism
it's in this one school and he kind of
presented it's not like he didn't know
about the other schools for example let
me just make that clear he very much was
one of the main people who put together
an actual book a source book in Indian
philosophy with Charles Moore that
contained like all these texts and
everything so he he was vastly
knowledgeable highly skilled rhetorician
an outstanding scholar but he made some
choices about what to present and he
decided that this was one of the things
that he wanted to make clear to other
people about Indian philosophy it turns
out that as he already knew that
incorrect to think that this is the only
School in vant first of all specific so
ADV vant has become synonymous with viic
thinking in a lot of the places outside
of in India and even in India that's all
that people know that's completely wrong
there are several schools of vant the
one I work on is actually the one from
ramanuja which is called V vant there's
AAA there's there's MVA there's a whole
I mean there's it just goes on it
literally just go there's like a lot lot
of these old sub schools and they have
very different views about what's going
on in the Vic tradition so that's one
thing and then the second thing is that
ADV vant became kind of a lens where
people would then look at the philosophy
of the yoga school and try to interpret
it through AIC lens when its actual
Roots were in the Sonia tradition it's a
sister School of the Sonia tradition and
so Sania and vant are not the same in a
lot of ways even many of the schools of
vant are different than Sania but there
was a tendency to try and like interpret
even Sania in relationship to yoga
through viic eyes and so this became
this this large Enterprise and one of
the things that came along with this um
was kind of this idea
that this school is highly spiritual and
so this is like the vast depth of the
spirituality of the Indian tradition
coming forward and there was little
attention paid to the fact that Indian
philosophers had other attributes as
well that were also interesting and good
and what did some of those things have
to do with well one of the things that
they had to do with was rationality and
logic that for example is very important
the other thing that it had to do with
was uh theories of knowing the other
thing it had to do with was realism
about the world as opposed to idealism
about the world so I predominantly work
on what's known as daa school which is a
realist School uh and it's an opponent
of of various forms of Buddhism and I
work on ramanuja because he's a realist
actually unlike um shankra who's either
an Illusionist or relative realist so I
tend to think that the Indian schools
that were engaged in realism had
something to offer as well and they have
interesting ideas and debates with these
schools that are more idealistic and
they offer contributions that are less
welln and sometimes it's so it's like
the thing like oh we're we're going to
go get pizza we're going to an Italian
restaurant we're going to go say some
Indian philosophy we're we're going to
learn some Von that's basically kind of
what I told and I don't and I want to
make it clear I I don't know enough
about the political situation of a time
period in which R Krishnan was coming I
know he's an extremely aidite scholar
and I don't blame him in any way for
what he did there might have been
political issues going on with the birth
of India that made him think hey this is
you know something that's important
because I can put this spirituality of
ADV in so he wrote this book where he
talked about how spirituality is
consistent with science he actually a
title of the book science and
spirituality and so he was concerned
with wanting to you know make things you
know better but his the person who
replaced him at Oxford Kish M La was a
nayaka and so he uh for the next longest
time basically expounded on the Nia
school and the relevance of it to
debates in contemporary epistemology and
logic he studied with v W Quin at
Harvard University and was a
contemporary of PF straon at Oxford he
wrote perhaps my favorite book in Indian
philosophy perception and essay on
classical Indian ways of knowing um
which is a phenomenal work that engages
a lot of um uh analytic philosophy of
the time period as well as Indian
philosophy and is also the inspiration
for my continued efforts to follow by
developing theories of perception in
Indian philosophy along with um analytic
philosophy now so that's a little bit of
like the story line that I think is is
common among Scholars to know that that
this there was this change of sort of um
things and now there's become like a
reemergence almost of interest in ADV
Vidant because of the Contemporary
debates on theories of Consciousness so
in that Air Field what has happened is
as you saw when I came to mfest at
Susan's conference there is a growing
interest in the fact that some of the
most contemporary moves being made in
debates about Consciousness such as the
pan psychist versions theories promoted
by lots of people nowadays um have
strong resonances with very important
Trends in Indian philosophy and so
there's a lot of work being done now to
understand how that conversation can
unfold as well boy you said like a
litany that's just
fascinating thanks there's quite a few
threads so one of them is there are some
people who watch videos like this and
they're in the west and they feel like
they know plenty about the east or
Buddhist Traditions or viic traditions
because they've watched Allen Watts or
maybe read a couple books and done
psychedelics and they have this Insight
that's fairly prevalent in these circles
that rationality and logic are the
opposite of what you need in order to
get some handle on the truth or reality
and you just mentioned that rationality
and logic is something that wasn't
advertised as coming from the East it's
more the non-dist ADV V vienta that was
so can you please expound on that and
then also there may be a couple terms
that come up that when they wait do do
you just to clarify you want me to
expound on what the relationship is
between these the the development of
rationality and logic in India and its
relationship to these other
non-dualistic ideas yeah yeah the fact
that you can understand not just with
irrationality and experience but
something analytic something logical
when I say understand I mean get to know
oneself or get to know reality or get to
know God or religion or spirituality
because it's generally seen as two
approaches one is more experiential and
one's more analytic and the West is seen
as more analytic and the East is seen
more experiential I'm painting broad
Strokes I'm just saying yeah I'm sure
you see this as well okay and while
you're explaining this some terms may
come up like Illusionist or idealist or
realist or relative realist when they
come up naturally explain them please
okay sure thank you that's a that's a
very good question and I think it's
um it's something that I think my
experience in writing and in research
can sort of um shed some light on in an
insightful way so one of the things I
think that is a nice place to start is
by looking at a common
interpretation and presentation of
Buddhism in the west uh it's also found
in India but where a lot of what is the
standard sort of thing to talk about
there is mindfulness meditation it is
taken to be something that is spent sort
of undergone a lot of neuroscientific
Investigation I even know some of the
people who work on that stuff it's also
something that has attracted a a wide
audience uh from various different types
of people and there's something about
mindfulness meditation that's healing it
clearly has this property for lots of
people and there's a tendency to want to
be interested in this component of
Buddhism uh not negatively in the sense
of like I'm just going to put everything
else away but just you know that's the
thing that's that's that's the pizza for
Buddhism basically
um so one of the things that I have
found in my research and I actually uh
wrote a fairly large piece on this
actually because I spend so much time
thinking about it was that it is uh not
historically accurate at all to think
that Buddhists weren't involved in the
development of logical ideas or that
they themselves did not engage in some
of the most veh arguments with their
opponents so daky is considered to be
Danga and daky are considered to be two
of the most
important uh Buddhist philosophers after
narina uh and the Buddha himself
obviously uh and they spent a lot of
time thinking about the rules for proper
reasoning and about ways of knowing
about the world um their work is not so
much presented in the discussion and
conversation about
meditation and how to live one's life as
you might find for example with people
who talk about Shanti DEA so pild has a
nice book about Shanti Deva and um I
think a lot of people go to these kinds
of works or they go to the works that
are talking about what to do with the
stuff that arises in Consciousness in
terms of living a life and being
compassionate and um these are first of
all I'm just I want to make it clear to
your audience like in no way am I
disparaging that I have spent time
myself meditating I we to go to a
Buddhist center like two times a week
I've done Vasa in India and everything
so on LD right
now so but but but the the thing I want
to say is that it is just factually
incorrect that they weren't engaged and
thought logical reasoning was very
important the evidence is just too much
and in fact I can point you just to one
780 page book by Daniel Perdue which is
a study of reasoning methods within the
Buddhist tradition within the mamaa and
Tibetan Buddhist Traditions it's an
extremely powerful book it might not be
accurate about everything that they came
up with but um it definitely shows the
rigorous the analyticity so the
analytical nature right of their minds
and I think it's very clear that
actually learning to argue and learning
to understand your own emotions through
meditation and emotion regulation are
two things that Buddhists care about I I
don't I think that the the thing that
you know pushing the sort of one line is
an incorrect thing if you enjoyed that
clip then the full podcast is out right
now you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI